hello everybody hope they are good today
it's a big day for the markets we have
the fomc meeting we're gonna have your
own power speaking that's why I'm here
and we're gonna talk a bit about this
fomc meeting what we can expect in this
meeting and in the next one okay so this
is what the market is expecting this is
what the market is pricing in okay uh I
don't think I've ever seen
but it is for a long time something as
clear as this 96.5 percent
are expecting that they hike 25 basis
points because right now we are at 5 25
basis points of 125 and they are
expecting
550 by the end of the day okay so that's
25 basis points high this has been to be
honest quite accurate in the last few
months so uh I'm trusting this I think
um anything else that it's not a hike of
25 basis points it's extremely extremely
extremely likely so I'm not even
considering the idea okay it's gonna be
25 basis points uh then what it gets
more interesting is what the market is
expecting for the next meetings okay and
this is where today's Jerome Powell
press conference is going to be very
interesting because maybe what I'm going
to show you now can change okay well you
know that in August we don't have an
m4mc meeting but in September we do okay
from September again now in September
what the market is expecting is to hold
the interest rates of 550 okay no change
all right only 20 are expected a new
hike but
um this goes in line with the effect has
been doing before okay because remember
that in June they they post now in July
that hiking in September they are
probably gonna post and in November
they're probably gonna hike that's what
the market is trying to understand okay
you can see that in September
they said a 20 chances that they hike
but in November those cents are high
okay 35 percent so I mean this uh this
can change based on what Jerome Powell
says today as another statement is going
to be very neutral and well we can get
some Clues is gonna be in the press
conference okay so I believe the uh the
fmcf statement and the news of our new
hike of 25 basis points shouldn't
necessarily
make the price move into One Direction
okay but what happens during the press
conference well so I recommend you to
not trade until at least 30 minutes
after the press conference finishes to
avoid any unnecessary risk
and then that's when we can look for
some clues for example they're probably
gonna ask him if there is going to be a
new hike let's see what he says because
that question is when I change these
percentages okay
for September November and that's going
to be very interesting also what about
the rate Goods they're probably even
asking about you what are good rates
this year
because to be honest here in December
I think that the market is you know
expecting a rate good here
57 okay the respect in a rate good or at
least that's what I understand from this
chart now these are the types of things
that you need to look for during the
press conference I just hope that it's
not a boring one like I think the
previous one was very boring I hope to
sing I hope it's not happening and he
actually gives you some Clues but this
is why everyone is expected also today
there is not Dot Plot The Dot Plot is
the economic projections of the Fed
I want a half day in September that
happens every three months so we got one
in March we're gonna we had one in June
we're gonna have one in September and
one in December okay so today 26th of
July don't expect a DOT product because
there is not going to be it happens
every three months okay uh because I saw
some people in Twitter talking about a
lot Platinum today there won't be a Dot
Plot now let me show you a different
chart okay
a follower called Philip sent me this
chart to me uh he made it so here is his
Twitter account okay that's the robot so
thank you very much for sharing it with
me and letting me use it in this video
but uh what I want you to see here first
is that uh this shows Bitcoin okay so
this chart over here well let me change
the color because I don't want to see
here okay uh okay this chart that you
see over here
that is Bitcoin okay so I want you to
focus in this chart over here okay
focusing this one over here does Bitcoin
in linear mode
now uh this is a daily time frame in
Bitcoin over here and you can see that
this chart is now full of data the case
from a few days ago but you can see the
Bitcoin did something like this okay
and were currently over here you can see
that here all right now
let's see what Bitcoin has been doing in
the past fomc dates and CPI dates that's
when there is Major news announcements
so the first thing that we can see is
that
um Bitcoin is going up then you have CPI
okay these doted red lines and Bitcoin
makes a new high let's continue Bitcoin
is going up then you have the fomc
meeting
dotted green lines okay then Bitcoin
makes a new high let's continue
CPI date okay Bitcoin is going up you
have the news announcements of CPI you
got a new high so you can see that
Bitcoin is following the trend let's
continue FMC meeting okay Bitcoin is
going down you have their Pharmacy
meeting then you see a new low continue
FMC date here okay Bitcoin is going up
then you have the fluency date and it
makes a new high you can see that this
high
is higher than the previous one okay
let's continue CPI date okay Bitcoin is
going up CPA CPI data Ambit who makes a
new high all this time you can see the
same thing as you can see here you can
see here and now
also you can see here a new high and now
if you notice
Bitcoin right now is doing something
like this okay let me Mark it for you
okay and you're gonna have a dotted line
coming like this this way okay what do
you think is happening Bitcoin has been
going down so the most likely thing is
that Bitcoin makes a new low
that's what I think because all the time
for the past what's in January
Bitcoin follows the news maybe in the
same day you see a small reversal Bull
in at least in the daily time frame you
see Bitcoin following the trend after
the news have been released so that
makes me think that if not Bitcoin has
been retracing because Bitcoin right now
is like this okay you see Bitcoin has
been going down and you have to wait
more news Bitcoin could make a new low
in the next days all right that's what I
take from the previous data regarding
news announcements now let's go back to
Bitcoin now the question is if Bitcoin
falls in the next days
what is it gonna go to all right and in
my opinion is this potential Support
over here okay that's at 28
337 why because you have here these
previous two resistances
okay so if Bitcoin decides to fall in
the next few days like it has been doing
you know according to that chart he
always follows the data then we should
probably aim for this level okay in the
next coming days
um of course this idea would be
invalidated
if we make another deviation here and to
confirm that what I need is to see
Bitcoin getting back above 29 500
testing your support or consolidating
above this resistance or this previous
support and then that's when Bitcoin
could push higher to the mid-range okay
but again uh I don't see this likely
happening why because with a new hike of
25 basis points the idea is that the
dollar should be going higher Bitcoin
should trade against dollar go lower yes
you can say yeah but the market has been
pricing in that for the last few days
and I'll agree with you dollar has been
going up Bitcoin has been going down in
anticipation to today's FMC meeting but
if you still want to see Bitcoin going
higher today or in the next days okay
I'm making this deviation you need to
hear Jerome power quite dovish today
otherwise
his situational repeat itself and you
might see another drop to this level
now if we check in hybrid Capital at the
liquidation levels in the seven days
time frame you can notice that there is
still quite a low liquidity below
between 28
828 650 Okay so
if that's the case that they are set to
bring price lower then you can
understand that these two expects here
the lows and this uh sideways okay Above
This zone is basically to make the
trader
opening lungs so there is more long
liquidations
stacked in this zone so you can see how
the yellow bar gets bright and bright
and brighter the more we consolidate
here okay that's because they are trying
to induce traders to open Longs okay
before bringing price down that's what
the narrative would say so the only
thing to invalidate this again is if
your own power comes out today and he
says look
I think we're gonna do this hike
and no more okay we're gonna stop here
maybe there are rate Cuts this year
I'm not gonna be that
strict saying no to rate Cuts this year
now cut this happen I really doubt it I
really doubt this can happen Okay
um I think either it's gonna be a really
boring press conference
or it's gonna be a really boring press
conference but we're gonna hear Jerome
Powell saying you know yes inflation is
coming down but the labor market is
still very strong so we have to be data
dependent there might be new hikes
because if we don't do new hikes then
there is a risk that inflation comes
higher again I think that's what he's
gonna say I'm actually quite curious to
hear what he says but I think that's
going to be the line okay but if they
ask him about the rate Cuts this year I
think that's going to be the main
question at least for me okay I wanna
hear what he says again because in a in
two months ago I think he said very
strongly nope not right because this
year now the market is still pricing in
at least one red crew this year so let's
see what he has to say if they ask him
that question okay guys so please be
very careful fomc starts today at 6 pm
uh the press conference starts at half 6
PM usually takes around 45 minutes or so
so I would say that it is done trade
until half past seven okay 7 30 UTC time
um that's pretty much everything guys be
very careful today try to close out your
positions before the data gets released
to avoid any spikes in price okay and I
wish you the best thank you so much for
watching and I'll see you soon